now we're gonna make the salsa okay
cherry tomatoes cut in half but not off
choking runners out okay now I know you
love to martyrs yeah let's go
now these are delicious it's a vibrant
salsa because brilliantly with a scallop
and more importantly you sort of combine
that with the coriander the basil the
olives and it just sort of melts
together a perfect combination for the
scallops hey Chris careful with that
knife yes it's not I'm nervous and I've
got a very sharp knife down oh you're so
used to take away plastic knives aren't
you but yeah yeah so be careful yes I'm
barely being careful bucko try and put
two tomatoes together and cut two let's
not get cocky I know really right
okay pan olive oil yes just two or three
tablespoons yes turn that on a low heat
come on Chris you're falling behind and
do it and I'll catch up on this girl so
as we pour it in yeah yep inward the big
one yeah okay okay oh come on come on
there you go down don't have to I've
done it yeah yeah okay good I know how
wrong [ __ ] parent I see this pan here
dad fair oh dear twice the mighty right
olive all in there
let's go olive oil in there it seems
like okay okay okay good dear oh dear
I'm also gonna help crispy tomatoes at
home you should be at this stage by now
oil in the pan right in Japan look
olives in there as well price okay yeah
good but pour the olives in yes all of
them quick
I'm done I feel good right tomatoes in
yes yeah it's not your timer yes you did
yes yeah a minute I want to go so okay
right okay some others in there olive
oil okay